hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the amnesia custom
story poisonous okay anyway I'm back
here now so I already know the code so I
can like do this and let's see if my
game does not crash one three five one
down and six ah there we are
okay find you and okay thank you baby
oh thank you so much but how are you
gonna get long tad how is you gonna do
that oh okay anyway I'll leave you to
your own devices topless lady looks very
Man esque again what are you kidding me
why why the game just crashed oh you
gotta be kidding me
it happened again this something about
that moment where the game just crashes
III don't know why and that sucks
because it didn't save beforehand
oh man that says alright I'll be back
when I can I so unfortunate that the
game just crashes right there it's like
just a giant pain okay I'll be back
hello everybody I'm back III don't know
what the deal is I really don't know I
wish like I knew but it's just something
that's
that's bugging me okay i'ma try this one
more time then I'm gonna get out of here
like as soon if I get it
get out get go get out yeah yeah yeah
yeah shut shut up lady out both of them
it's both of them
oh no okay all right I'm out of here
don't crash don't crash don't crash
don't crash whoo here we go okay I got
it
yeah hey booth yeah all right so I if I
will have a chance to escape I need to
blow up this bridge
maybe the nitroglycerin will work where
do I blow it up where do I blow it up
where I'm Lana where do I blowed up I
didn't blow it up the right place I did
not blow it up at the right place okay
taking another shot
haha all the votive there's gonna be
like something there if I really have a
chance to escape I need to blow this
bridge up maybe the nitroglycerin
referred how about right here ah boom
God we may better throw it from the
distance or something is Li lounged me
ah oh I thought it was like two eyes
uh-huh I still don't understand what
there was the point of that castle
that's freaky
I feel so much better now
whoa okay hey something over there what
duck what gah
haha what no way
what's that what the hell oh there's
like a thing down there
ha ha I was so confused I've never seen
that before little what okay
yike boom I don't eat this
probably won't even let me go yep
invisible walls all right
so now I go down this interesting little
passage free get out of my way foosh I
push you bish okay
under the dark tunnel of doom
left looks like a dead end dead end down
there though just have to check double
check always to make sure okey-dokey
all right
seems like it might be the end of the
game and yo alright
ah the you say it was true but two
monsters have been killing people for
centuries that here now they are dead no
they are dead what surprises me is that
even these monsters once you nuts I got
the order once humans wonder what made
them into these terrifying creatures
merely the poison water maybe maybe it
was the poison water oh well that makes
it poisonous Oh
oh yeah the barrels the barrels are
radioactive material in the first
episode oh whoa okay I get it
yeah alright anyway short the bugs in
the last bit kind of spoiled it a bit
but still great great great custom story
like real it was really good I would
suggest anyone to play that I mean a
short sweet the voice acting was yeah
but you know you do the best you can
with what you have I mean not everyone
has access to real legit voice actors so
they got to do it their own self in I
don't mean to criticize guy I applaud
the guy for putting himself out there
like that I'm just poking fun at him so
anyway that was awesome so thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
enjoyed it let me know in the comments
if you want me to play another custom
story if you have one in mind
I'm always open to suggestions so thank
you all so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next part
bye bye